the prime minister's own Deputy Prime
Minister Christia Freeland said that
covet was a political opportunity and
and his former Finance Minister Bill no
Borneo says that the Prime Minister used
vaccines as a wedge issue to divide
people
and thus
a lot of people were so helpless
and so desperate
they ended up participating in a protest
in Ottawa
this was an emergency that Justin
Trudeau created by attacking his own
population by driving up their cost of
living by making it impossible for
people to pay their bills and live their
lives in peace he caused the emergency
that unfolded and then when he caused it
He piled on he poured more gasoline on
the fire with nasty insults jabbing his
finger in the faces of his own citizens
something that even today's report
acknowledged contributed to the length
and the intensity of the protest Justice
rule said that he did not accept the
organizer's descriptions of the protest
as lawful calm peaceful or something
resembling a celebration
he wrote that the bigger picture reveals
the situation in Ottawa was unsafe and
chaotic Justice rule also found that the
federal government's use of the
emergencies Act was justified do you
accept Justice Rule's findings and do
you regret endorsing the freedom Convoy
well first of all you your question was
typical of CBC biased again you uh
forgot to mention what the report said
which is
um more more of an effort should have
been made by government leaders at all
levels during the protest to acknowledge
that the majority of protesters were
exercising their fundamental Democratic
rights
what I said before during and after the
protest was that I condemn anyone who
behaves badly breaks flaws or blockades
critical infrastructure while standing
on the side of the hard-working people
who have suffered so much under eight
years of Justin Trudeau and we're
desperately trying to have their voices
heard against an insulting and divisive
prime minister
and the only reason that we had this
emergency is because Justin Trudeau
wanted it to happen
because he wanted to distract and divide
Canadians from the pain and suffering
that he has caused by driving up their
cost of living making it possible for
our youth to own homes by taxing our
working class and by imposing
unnecessary and unscientific rules that
brought an end to the livelihoods of
countless Heroes we needed for our
economy thank you given the release of
the public order emergency commission's
report and Rising Western alienation it
clear it's clear there is divisions
among Canadians what role does prime Min
has prime minister show played in this
Division and how can it be resolved
he hasn't played a role he is the
division
his purpose is to divide and conquer he
believes that if he can turn Canadians
against each other then they'll forget
how miserable life has become after
eight years of his tax hikes inflation
and out of control cost of living
with costs crime and Corruption raging
after eight years of Justin Trudeau it's
no wonder he wants to focus off him and
he wants Canadians fighting with each
other so you can expect him to continue
to divide people by race region vaccine
status and any other fault line that he
can invent